[Applause]
[Music]
earthquakes earthquakes are one of the
natural phenomena that have impacted the
history of mankind the most
[Music]
they've destroyed entire cities and
taken the lives of millions upon
millions of people that's really nothing
new what is new is knowing how to resist
them how to survive and make safer
buildings and safer infrastructure this
is indeed a very new phenomenon and when
it comes to earthquake proofing there
are two countries that have had to learn
a lot Chile and Japan are two of the
most seismically active countries on the
planet
[Music]
together they account for almost 40
percent of all seismic activity that
happens in the world in fact Chile has
suffered the most powerful earthquake
ever recorded the Valdivia earthquake in
1960 they recorded a magnitude of 9.5 on
the Richter scale
a true Cataclysm but this is not so
unusual when you consider that both
Japan and Chile lie directly above the
Ring of Fire a stretch of 40,000
kilometers that accounts for most of the
seismic and volcanic activity on earth
in this zone tectonic plates subduct
that is one slides under the other
generating subduction zones the movement
of the plates is not constant or regular
it happens with southern poles and when
both plates are very stressed and have a
lot of accumulated energy they yield let
go and move suddenly generating strong
earthquakes that is why 90% of all
earthquakes in the world and 80% of the
most powerful ones the megathrust happen
in the Ring of Fire in fact Japan and
Shelley's earthquakes are very similar
in magnitude and duration as you can
imagine this challenge comes with one
choice and that's adapt we all die today
on visual politic we're gonna tell you
how these countries managed to adapt
what the main differences between them
are and the great common challenge that
Japan and Chile face so listen up
Chile and Japan learning from mistakes
the most destructive earthquakes have
terrible consequences we're talking
about phenomena that can end the lives
of tens of thousands of people in just a
few minutes to sin think Chile and Japan
are the most advanced countries in
seismic disaster prevention for one
simple reason throughout their history
they've undergone terrible tragedies
that have taught them a very valuable
lesson it's worth spending more at the
outset to save on human and
reconstruction costs para que te kotahi
lumbus more to better illustrate the
magnitude of what we're talking about
here let's focus on just one example
marks the 11th 2011 is one of those
dates that we all surely remember that
day a huge 9.1 magnitude earthquake was
centered on the Miyagi Prefecture in
Japan but it shook a large part of the
country including the capital of Tokyo
the Great Eastern earthquake and the
subsequent tsunami left almost 16,000
people dead and more than 6,000 injured
and yes we're talking about the same
earthquake that caused the Fukushima
disaster
this was Japan's latest mega-quake but
the Japanese know that there's a 70%
chance of another mega earthquake
happening in Tokyo in the next 30 years
[Music]
and yes okay the vast majority more than
85% of Tokyo's buildings are considered
resistant but the fact that sixteen
thousand hectares of the Japanese
capital is covered in wooden buildings
that does not help
according to song simulations the gas
leaks that are commonly produced by a
large earthquake could cause fires
throughout the city and could destroy
more than 600,000 buildings so the
consequences they go far beyond tremors
and possible landslides and of course
all of this generates awareness both
social and political meanwhile in Chile
they are somewhat behind but the shock
of 2010 made them take risk prevention
even more seriously an eight point eight
magnitude earthquake shakes Chile the
earthquake lasting one minute was felt
in the capital where the electrical
service was interrupted the tsunami that
the earthquake caused reached Hawaii
Chile's earthquake affected 70% of the
country's population but thanks to
anti-seismic regulations only two of the
capital's high-rise buildings collapsed
and in the face of such a strong
earthquake that was actually quite a
success especially considering the
precedence of the Latin American region
Chile's investments in resilient
infrastructure early warning systems and
urban planning have managed to ensure
that this time the number of victims is
low
despite the earthquakes intensity
Margareta Wahlstrom former office
special representatives of the United
Nations for disaster risk reduction
[Music]
and this is what we need to repeat as
the saying goes better safe than sorry
but how of Japan and Chile achieved
these levels of risk prevention how do
their models differ what are the
weaknesses and what are the keys to
saving lives
[Music]
if there's a risk get ahead of it when
we talk about earthquakes we must keep
two things in mind they're unpredictable
and they're inevitable however what can
be predicted and avoided are the risks
that arise when an earthquake occurs you
see earthquake damage prevention can be
done in two ways active or passive for
example after the Valdivia earthquake of
1960 the strongest ever recorded which
caused a huge tsunami the pacific
tsunami warning system and mitigation
system was created by the unesco
Intergovernmental oceanographic
Commission in 1965 intending to
disseminate early tsunami alerts
but don't worry the age of the system
shouldn't scare you it's been updated
over time the fact is that this is one
of the best examples of active
prevention
the tsunami in the Pacific has a huge
propagation capacity and it can be very
destructive usually there is about a 20
to 30 minute window between an
earthquake happening under a row near
the sea and a tsunami hitting the
nearest coast but in the case of the
2011 earthquake in Japan in some areas
only two minutes passed before the alert
and the tsunami making landfall and of
course in the cases of phenomena that
require massive evacuations and which
affect huge regions early warnings are
massively important the more time people
have the better and every second really
does count
in fact a strong earthquake originating
in Chile can cause such a large tsunami
that it can affect very distinct coasts
throughout the Pacific such as Japan New
Zealand America and even the Philippines
and that is precisely why Japan also
implemented its own early warning system
which has been greatly improved since
the 2011 catastrophe since that year
more than twenty five billion dollars
have been invested into earthquake
sensors to reach two hundred and eighty
points it's the densest and most
reliable network in the world
however the biggest challenge by far is
passive prevention that is all those
measures and standards that aim to
minimize damaged buildings and therefore
the number of victims and in this Japan
is the undisputed leader Japan's strict
building codes save lives but how
exactly does it work well check this out
although the first Japanese anti-seismic
construction regulations date back to
1924 most of the buildings have been
built under two very different
regulations the oldest one called kyo
tycion dates back to 1950 and focused on
preventing buildings collapsed the new
Kyoto Shin Thai shitin from 1981
requires buildings to remain
structurally sounds and show at most
only cracks after medium to strong
earthquakes these rules have evidently
been partially reinforced over the years
it's precisely due to this that the
structures of the buildings in Japan are
mostly made out of steel which is much
more flexible and resistant movement
than Richard Congress furthermore in
some cases cross beams that absorb
energy from the earth Quaker also
installed and of course they also have
seismic dampers at the base of the
tallest buildings Chile on the other
doesn't require buildings to withstand
damage regulations are more oriented
towards preventing their collapse its
current regulation is more similar to
the Japanese one of 1950 in this aspect
you can see the huge difference in
vision that Chile has where regulation
is much less strict that is to say in
Chile they seek to save lives but
without requiring buildings to remain
unscathed and there's really a
fundamental reason for this and that's
the cost
[Music]
building a building as resilient as
those in Japan can cost around 10 to 15%
more than a regular one and of course
this makes housing prices in newer and
more resistant buildings more expensive
the philosophy is if you live here
you'll be safe
but hold on just a second we're assuming
that rules are always met and codes are
always followed and that everyone is
working for the common good when the
truth might be rather different in fact
you know what the number one problem is
that affects security and can cost many
lives well think about it for a second
maybe you got it
[Music]
attention corruption kills yes you heard
that correctly it might surprise you but
corruption is without a doubt to the
greatest threat to security in terms of
earthquakes and no neither Japan nor
Chile are free of this scourge because
even though Japan has the image of an
ideal country and Chile ranks in acid'
respectable number 27 in the corruption
perception index from time to time
scandals like this one crop up the KYB
corporation a Japanese company dedicated
to the development and manufacture of
seismic dampers admitted at the end of
2008 that they had falsified the quality
and performance data of their products
for more than a decade to date they
haven't yet been able to quantify the
real scope of the risk that this entails
but it's estimated that the
effectiveness of the falsified products
could be at around 86% of the minimum
requirements required by law buildings
as important as Tokyo City Hall's the
Olympic Aquatic Centre in the ariake
arena home of the 2020 Olympic Games
used seismic dampers from this company
and as if that wasn't enough the tallest
tower in the world does to Tokyo Skytree
among buildings linked to data scandal
at earthquake shock absorber maker KYB
corporation although this case is quite
serious the truth is that Japan doesn't
have much corruption and that means that
seismic regulations are followed most of
the time
chili on the other hand has the lowest
corruption level in all of Latin America
which is contributed to the facts that
anti-seismic regulations in construction
are complied with in the vast majority
of cases although as we've seen they are
less stringent than Japan's we have a
law that states the design of a certain
height must be reviewed by an
independent team that verifies that the
standards are being met no one builds
without this backing Sergio super Veda
geology scholar from the University of
Chile to LPE
you know what it's precisely this broad
compliance with regulations that makes
Chile a much safer country to live in
than for example Mexico during an
earthquake
corruption and negligence caused
landslides during Mexico City earthquake
Mexico one of the countries with the
highest corruption rates in the region
is also a seismically active country
the difference with chili is that in
Mexico cities every time there's a
strong earthquake several buildings
collapse leaving numerous victims and
although not all earthquakes have the
same characteristics but reasons such as
the type of soil and depth Mexico City
lost 228 people in the city alone and
369 across the entire country when an
earthquake hit on September the 19th
2017 on the other hand the 2015
earthquake in Kimbo Chile which was felt
with an intensity of 7 in Santiago only
caused 15 fatalities throughout the
country
this is a great example of earthquake
prevention there for Mexico and other
highly seismic countries need to catch
up and work hard and honestly for the
safety of their citizens
[Music]
so I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did please don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also please do check
out our friends at the reconsider media
podcast we provided the vocals in this
episode but well not mine also this
channel is possible because of patreon
and our patrons on that platform please
consider joining them and supporting us
in our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always i'll
see in the next video
[Music]